welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Marvel's
what if season 2 episode 9 the season
finale what if strange Supreme
intervened looks like Stevie strange
never learned any lessons from season 1
so let's shake out his big toy box and
break down all the Easter eggs the
cameos the animation details all the
stuff you miss and the deeper layer of
meaning that this series is establishing
about Nexus beings like Captain Carter
The Watcher and God of stories Loki now
yes I am easing back for my paternity
leave to cover for Jessica on what if
coverage while she been feeling under
the weather but please go watch her
amazing breakdowns of episodes 1 through
six in huge thanks to the new Rockstar
content team for their hard work on all
of these Jessica Clemens John Costa Gina
EO Brandon barck Noah Chen and to all of
our editors okay the Marvel Studios
title card has now been updated with all
animated what if versions of these MCU
characters past moments the first script
line we see is I am Iron Man and now
credited to sakar Iron Man and we see
Tony's gnarly SAR Hulkbuster suit from
episode 4 then an image of the freak
version of of happy Hogan with his line
from episode 3 oh I got Hulk blood
pumping through me Star-Lord tala from
season 1 episode 2 what if tchala became
Star-Lord with the line there's an
entire world out there Baba which he
said as a boy to tchaka at the beginning
of the episode Bill Foster from Season 2
Episode 2 and his line go big or go home
cordi from season 2 episode 6 then an
interesting one Red Guardian Alexis
shustov he never showed up in seasons 1
or two but he will show up in season 3
because Marvel either intentionally or
accidentally released a whole scene in
which there will be a teamup episode
with Bucky Barnes and Alexi and Bill
Foster is going to show up from that
episode I guess he is given a line here
I am the Knight I am the wi then we see
strange Supreme the villain or perhaps
tragic hero of the series and then
Captain Carter is holding her Shield out
at us in the same position where
normally in this sequence Steve Rogers
is tossing his shield at us we see her
do that through the explosions next and
we see her script line the names Captain
Carter and I really love how all of
these character designs get sketched
into form before they are Inked in which
is how comic books are manufactured
there is a pencil and then there's an
inchor and continuing this Marvel
Studios intro the Marvel letters come
together showing a ton of moments from
this what if series we see the Watcher
silhouetted in the Stars Captain Carter
in the very first episode when she
charges in with the hen Commandos we see
J training Hela from season 2 episode 7
strange Supreme from season 1 episode 9
Tony on thear in his armor as it
transforms into the race car in season 2
episode 4 kohori from episode 6 Hydra
stomper Steve from season 2 episode 5
and Captain Carter when they were back
to back 1602 Hulk from season 2 episode
8 1602 Merlin Wanda from that episode
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers from season
1 episode 7 Star-Lord tchala from season
1 episode 2 Carol and party Thor
fighting in season 1 episode 7 zombie
Scarlet witch from season 1 episode 5
you can see her in the hole of the r
there then ego from earlier the season
in episode two Peggy coming out of the
super soldier machine in Project rebirth
in the very first episode of the series
Tony sitting in the ry's donuts donut
from season 1 episode 3 the grandmas
from the Sakara episode season 2 episode
4 Queen ramonda from season 1 episode 6
Natasha with Red Guardian Shield that
was from season 1 Howard the Duck from
season 2 episode 1 Gamora from season 2
episode 4 young Peter Quill from Season
2 Episode 2 Nick Fury Carol Danvers
pucky Barnes Ultron Infinity for the
final two episodes of season 1 or that
might have been from his Cameo at the
very end of episode 7 and strange
Supreme and then a very quick flash of
zombie Steve Rogers from season 1
episode 5 okay so the Watcher brings us
back to the end of last episode London
1602 where Captain Peggy Carter was
stranded after restoring this timeline
and purging all the Marvel characters
who were transported to Elizabeth in
England after Steve Rogers ruptured
thanos's time Stone The Watcher reminds
us of Peggy's Journey from the first
episode of the series defeating Hydra in
World War II going through the portal of
the present and the events of season 2
episode 5 leading to an alternate
Avengers lineup and fighting through the
Red Room trap in that Russian town and
joining 1602 Steve Rogers in the most
recent episode but it's interesting how
The Watcher is shown behind the thick
Dusty glass of this Pub window while
strange Supreme is on the inside
beinging their ale into single Mal
whiskey cuz remember last episode Peggy
said that she preferred whiskey whiskey
and this was like the drink that she and
skinny Steve shared in the very first
episode of the series and changing
drinks is a common parlor trick for
Doctor Strange remember he refilled
Thor's beer in Ragnarok and he turned
Christine's water into wine in
Multiverse Madness but strange is really
manipulating Captain Carter The Watcher
is on the outside looking in helpless to
stop him now season 1 episode 4 ended in
Bleak tragedy for strange Supreme it was
a cautionary tale and remember season
one never really resolved that even
though strange helped the Guardians of
the Multiverse stop Ultron and
killmonger none of that really healed
its heartbreak his grief has just gotten
worse and worse ever since then strange
asks Peggy if first run Shakespeare
isn't enough reminding us that
yesterday's 162 episode might have been
a specific destination nearby Loki god
of stories to Target the time the most
influential storytelling in the English
language was being composed by William
Shakespeare and to allow Loki to play
Hamlet and play Iago and misplace the
skull of York to an earlier scene from
Act five the act three in order to
stress momento Mori The Watcher Catches
Us up with the events of strange Supreme
from season 1 episode four in episode 9
reminding us that strange Supreme
destroyed his soul and Insanity to try
to spare Christine Palmer's life and the
Watcher says now two legends must band
together to face a threat unlike any the
Multiverse has ever faced ah but the
threat is not cohort it's strange
himself or rather the darkness that he
allowed to overtake him back in that
episode as in W division the greatest
danger is
truly no not today Mesto the greatest
danger is truly grief itself St brings
Peggy into a sanctum infinitum these
looming walls and high ceilings remind
us of the Lost library of cagliostro in
that season 1 episode 4 episode but if
it were redecorated by a goth into this
kind of dungeon imprisoned here are
various Universe killers that Strang has
captured in a sense he has become
something akin to The Collector or
Miguel O'Hara in across the spiderverse
with his captured Cannon breaking
villains our first glance of the
imprisoned Universe Killers includes
Ultron Infinity that gnome that strange
absorbed in season 1 episode 4 a version
of than knows the collector from season
1 episode 2 remember when he was like
super jacked what seems to be a
gunslinger Cowboy Loki that we get a
better look at later win woo from season
2 episode 7 and Hela but this is not the
white armored goddess of light Hela from
the end of season 2 episode 7 this Hela
is still in her dark armor and headpiece
and then on the opposite wall we see a
super armored version of rocket that we
see later there's the young Peter Quill
from Season 2 Episode 2 an armored Hulk
that we see later in this episode a
version of corvis glaive from thanos's
black order and a version of Thor now
you have to imagine each of these
characters come from some home Universe
where they just became the most powerful
God being like armored Hulk maybe
someone who threw the events of Thor
Ragnarok killed Thor and then overtook
Asgard and was like woried as like the
all father of this universe corvis
glaive I assume is someone who stabbed
Thanos in the back and then took the
Infinity Gauntlet for himself this
version of Rocket might be someone who
invented a gun that could just destroy
any god-killing weapon so that he would
have the only God killing weapon and
then I guess just a cowboy Loki now
Peggy correctly guesses that strange
Supreme let one of these Universe
Killers Escape Gremlins aliens Jurassic
Park collect enough dangerous well
anything and something always escapes
yeah Peggy is working through more of
her pop culture reference list after
referencing flux capacitor last episode
and it's worth noting that all three of
these movies involve finding egg sacks
of the species Peggy singling out movies
that involved Easter egg hunting and I
love it strange turns this dial with
runes and a window of portals open and
this seems to be Strange's rotunda of
gateways remember the portal room that
exists in the from s torum he swipes to
the South Dakota Badlands that looked
like they've been ravaged by a wildfire
but now it's winter and strange promises
that after Peggy finds the universe
killer he'll send her home but he says
cross my heart yeah Peggy should suspect
this because this strange has no heart
in this burnt Forest of South Dakota
Peggy sees that mount brushmore has been
defaced so that only Red Skull is there
which is especially haunting because Red
Skull was Peggy's first villain in this
Whata if series and it kind of reminds
us of Superman 2 when General Zod and
his crew reshaped Mount Rushmore and
just what wiped off Lincoln's face
because they didn't want to share it
with him the Watcher explains that the
explosive that was there in Project
rebirth in the SSR station that that
Hydra assassin detonated the events that
led to Peggy Carter becoming a super
soldier that now that explosion killed
both her and Steve that would allow Red
Skull to be able to use the Tesseract
and conquer the world but in this case
it's especially tragic for kahori to see
South Dakota ravaged this way by a
European Invader and powered by the Tess
Rak which would have been the same
instrument that gave her her power and
that she just wasn't there in this
history to stop him kohori Zips through
the snowy trees that reminds us of
quicksilver zipping Around The Avengers
in the opening of Age of Ultron and
sovia kohori attacks but Peggy tries to
repel her with the shield but then cordi
just catches The Shield the same way the
Winter Soldier catches Steve shield and
Captain America Winter Soldier and cordi
says that delusional or honored us is
lying to you I assume this term is a
mohawk insult as nearly all of episode 6
was in the Mohawk language and that was
just so cool to see them come into that
but it's interesting now that cordi can
speak English which might mean that like
over the years she was was able to pick
up the language pretty quickly can't
imagine she would have let the British
colonize the Americas in her reality and
I just don't really know how long
strange Supreme was chasing her I think
our girl is just pretty smart thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
you can love holiday season and also
admit that it's stressful travel time
with family marking time with new
years's it can be a lot and if you feel
like you could use a little help with it
all try connecting with a licensed
therapist by using Better Health
starting therapy can be hard the right
therapist for you may not be in your
area and some people struggle with the
face Toof face interaction of therapy
with better help you can have your
therapy sessions as a phone call as a
video chat even via messaging if you
prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with a therapist from
their Network that's right for you if
you don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist for no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who's in your network or
anything like that if you think that you
might benefit from therapy consider
better help click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com neww
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of betterhelp
so you can connect with a therapist and
see if it helps you strange drops both
of them back into the sanctum and Cordy
reveals that he is feeding both Universe
killers and righteous Heroes into this
Forge strange isn't trying to save
universes he's trying to resurrect his
universe and under this you can hear
Michael Chino's do strange theme but it
has a more Sinister upturn in the second
measure of it and we see why last
episode in included the tragic reminder
of Peggy's loss of Steve Rogers strange
Supreme hoped that that loss would make
Peggy Carter sympathetic to Strange's
plan to bring back Christiane Palmer at
any cost but Peggy resists and she sees
more prisoners on the wall including
that Gunslinger Cowboy Loki that we saw
before I assume he's one of the
righteous Heroes according mentioned
because I don't think this guy is
killing any universes we see this
interesting sorcerer with the time Stone
on his chest and it kind of looks like
the collector but there is a different
version of The Collector so I'm not sure
if this is like the collector or Odin or
version of Thor it's kind of hard to
tell then we see happy the free Hogan
there's also a version of Howard the
Duck which is fun and also an adult
Star-Lord either Peter Quill or tala
with either the portal Tentacles from
season 1 episode one or probably just
the extensions of ego's expansion from
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2 we also
see the great protector dragon that we
saw in talo and chungi that came back in
episode 7 of the season and so she
unleashes these prisoners and I love
using this tactic because reminds me of
the third Act of the cin in the woods
when all the iconic horror monsters were
Unleashed from their cages creating this
prison riot through which the heroes
could Escape so along with the ones that
we mentioned earlier in this video you
can also see a chitauri soldier vision
is there there's definitely The
Collector from season 1 episode 2 when
he was super jacked there's call
obsidian from thanos's black order later
this episode we also see Proxima
midnight so I think all four members of
the black order are there Captain Marvel
is there there's an Asgardian Soldier
there's a white-haired win woo in
Warriors from the tin Rings corg is
there that Little Gnome that I talked
about is there and then armored Hulk who
seems to be in Asgardian armor there's
the rocket I talked about before for
there's one of the Dark Elves that we
saw in the collector's Vault and he's
from th of the Dark World and in what if
season 1 episode 2 there's a whole bunch
of Scrolls who are there and then I
think you can see the back of draxx
fighting Hulk at one point so they run
away and they turn another corner and
run into zombie Scarlet witch from
season 1episode 5 when zombie Wanda
flies up to fight kahori the bearded
zombie behind her kind of looks like
Robert Kirkman who is the comics creator
of Marvel zombies and a producer on the
upcoming Marvel zombie show whenever
Marvel gets around to that and of course
the guy behind The Walking Dead and
invincible all these zombies eyes switch
from Wanda red to Hela green as Hela
rides up on the wolf Fenris Hela used
the same spell to resurrect the dead
Warriors and Asgard and Thor Ragnarok
and like Loki loves to do Hela demands
them to kneel but Cordy says that the
last woman to demand that from her
regretted it recalling Queen Isabella
back in episode 6 cter returns voiced as
always by Clancy Brown remember it was
CER who kills Hela and throw Ragnarok so
Hela cannot help but refocus her
attention on him so cordi and Peggy run
into whoop Thanos who prepares to use
all six Infinity Stones but because what
if never lets poor Thanos actually use
the six stones someone else snaps and
dust them away and it is honga yeah they
bring back killmonger's music from Black
Panther we see his Stone empowered armor
made of vibranium we saw kilmonger
wearing this at the end of season 1
episode 9 the finale so Gori just uses
her space manipulation powers to pull
kilmonger out of that suit and then
portal him away to the rest of the melee
where now we see two versions of Thor
both leaping toward each other with
their own respective milers Peggy
touches killmonger's armor and the
stones transfer to her leading to an
insane third Act of this episode where
they just keep upgrading their power
sets and their toys so they head into
the forge and that Forge looks like
electron rings of an atom or maybe that
Wormhole device on the movie contact
that I always bring up in videos Peggy
uses the Power Stone to strengthen her
Shield strange unleashes those serpent
heads that he used in battles last
season Peggy continues to use the power
Stone to bind the serpents around
strange and absorb his next attacks so
that she can redirect that energy into
the forge next Peggy uses a space stone
for her Shield teleporting it around
strange but strange is able to get one
step ahead of her so strange uses the
images of Icon spell like when he
battled Thanos an Infinity War creating
duplicates of himself but Captain Carter
uses the reality Stone to mirror that
spell the two sides wore it out until
strange waves his hand turning the
duplicates into butterflies which is the
kind of transfiguration spell that we
also saw him use on thanos's attacks in
Infinity War so Peggy is transported
back to her original what if moment in
the first episode of the series in
Project Rebirth of the SSR when Abraham
erskin asked if she'd be more
comfortable in the booth which was the
single question that put put her on her
new life path but Peggy sees a butterfly
and Steve says I love you and I think
it's that I love you that tips Peggy off
because Steve never would have said that
this early to her he was much too polite
so like the reality spell that Wanda
maximoff cast Over Doctor Strange In The
Orchard of Multiverse of Madness this is
just another smoke screen so strange
opens portals to drop the prisoners into
the forge including cord's friend a
terax from episode 6 so cordi tries to
lift everyone back up into newly blue
portals to take them home but this leads
to a kind of up and down tug of war
Peggy freezes it and tries to reverse
The Descent using the time Stone but
strange rber also has a Time Stone it's
still in his eye of aimoto that's really
what led him to go crazy in that episode
so now all the universe killers are
dropping and they take pity on Peggy
Carter Hela tosses her antlered helmet
she screams give him hell and this time
hell in the Clos captions is spelled
with just one L so it is the true as
guardian afterlife others donate a Muer
the 10 Rings Hulk Supreme sword which
I'm going to assume is the all father
Thor's vibranium sword that we saw last
episode and among these weapons is Odin
spear gungir cordi takes the Rings and
Moler Peggy takes the helmet and the
sword each of these hits revert strange
into that monstrous form that he took
late in season 1 episode 4 when his
eroding Soul gave way to this demon
monster who just used Strange's
appearance as kind of a skin that was
just a spell that that version of
strange was casting to not scare people
as much that demon has been his Dark
Passenger all this time and that Demon's
name is grief this monster absorbs each
of the powerful weapons he takes gungir
into his palm and it leaves a smiley
face he eats Moler the Infinity Stones
Get Knocked loose and Peggy leaps at
strange seemingly empty-handed to lower
his guard but a kohori flings the stones
into her fist at the last second so that
strange doesn't see the punch coming so
strange admits my grief is too strong
grief is too strong but if that
Monster's grief what did Vision tell us
grief truly is but what is grief if not
love persevering grief equals love
persevering so strange is able to detach
himself from this Dark Passenger by
letting go of his love for Christine
Palmer to truly love someone is to let
them go and he chooses to love Peggy and
kahori in the rest of the Multiverse
even more by dragging himself down with
his grief down into the forge The
Watcher takes Peggy into his fifth
dimensional viewing gallery and they see
Christine and Central Park during the
autumn in this reality where strange was
never born and this butterfly with teal
and purple wings lands on the Watcher's
finger now the butterflies that strange
used earlier were pink and red colored
this butterfly's colors are not random
green turning into into teal turning
into purple are the same colors of the
idril tree that the Watcher unveils to
Peggy Oh
Captain just you watch I cannot believe
that we were seeing this image in a
Marvel title after we first saw this
image just like 2 months ago it's
actually happening two different Marvel
Disney Plus shows are actually comparing
notes and communicating with each other
eer was the new shape of the temporal
Loom that Loki created in the final
episode of the Loki series which was a
way for him to organically weave and
wholesomely maintain the time stream
without having to violently prune it and
he did this at the cost of his own
happiness this is where the Watcher
leaves us and guides Peggy Carter that
bright green spot at the center that is
God of stories Loki right in there he's
keeping the porch light on for us this
tells us that God of stories Loki is not
as alone as we thought he and The
Watcher are sharing responsibility as
meta beings as Nexus beings working
together to keep the Multiverse in this
healthy State we are seeing a joining of
the liveaction and animated sides of the
MCU in a current Multiverse Saga and
setting the stage stage for Avengers 5
and Avengers Secret Wars we're seeing I
think one of the teams forming team Loki
that's going to include Loki The Watcher
and Captain Carter if the MCU is
building a battle World landscape I
think at the center of that field is
going to be eril that's the flag that
both teams are going to be trying to
capture and I think this butterfly with
idil's colors was God of stories Loki's
way of welcoming Captain Carter to the
team and thanks again to the new
rockstars team for letting me spend
December with our baby boy feel better
Jessica I cannot wait to talk about all
of this Insanity with you on New
rockstars in 2024 and I want to thank
all of you watching for spending time
with new rock stars throughout 2023 I'm
just so grateful to still be here doing
this please subscribe to all three of
our channels and you can support us with
some exclusive merch From Nerd rot. shop
follow me at eaos and I'll see you all
soon bye
everybody
he